a few days ago I asked
are there women out there who will refuse pregnancy to the extent they can
if Trump wins in November
this is the response I received
these are women who refuse to do reproductive labor
under a national abortion ban
because they're fully aware that the maternal mortality rate is skyrocketing
that in Texas alone it is up 56% after their abortion ban
these are women who are justifiably afraid of becoming pregnant
needing care and being unable to receive it
being told that we have to wait until you get worse before we can help you
we are unwilling to do reproductive labor
for a government that is forcing us to do it
a government that is still going to push these policies
even though they know it will raise the maternal mortality rate
if they're going to make us do this
and they don't care that it could cost us our health and even our life
then fine
we won't do it and I see that I am not alone
they are messing with the wrong people
and we will damn sure see them at the ballot box